[Music]
hello my name is yuri minja and i'm a
postdoctoral scientist at the
cedars-sinai medical center in los
angeles the work that i'm going to be
talking about today is the culmination
of collaboration between cedars-sinai
california institute of technology and
the center for theoretical neuroscience
at columbia university
this works this work looks at
representations of memory and choice in
the human brain and to the extent that
these representations are
modulated by the context or the task
that the subject is performing at any
given time so i'd like to start with a
few simple considerations
imagine that you're looking at an image
this could be an image that you took
while on a family vacation or you can it
can be a completely new image in any
case we know that there must be some
sort of internal representation that
arises from um the viewing of this image
and you could say that
the goal of of of most of what
neurosciences do is to try to learn what
this f of x actually is
what we're actually trying to do here is
not only measure these representations
that
of of visual representations and
representations of familiarity that a
person might have with this image but
also how these representations interact
with the task that the person is
currently engaged in
for example you may be wondering if this
is an image of a train or if this is an
image that you're familiar with
in either case you're looking for very
specific information that you're trying
to extract from this image
in this particular study we're going to
focus on two specific kinds of tasks in
one case we'll ask subject
categorization task
we'll show them an image and we can ask
them is this an image of a fruit or is
this an image of an apple
in a
different cluster of tasks we'll ask the
subject if they've seen this particular
image before
in addition we'll show them images of a
variety of different that are sampled
from a variety of different image
categories for example fruits faces cars
and monkeys
and to reiterate the goal of this entire
study is to find out to determine the
extent to which these visual
representations of these images are
modulated by the task that the subject
is currently engaged in
to address these questions we designed a
very simple task over a series of blocks
in this case eight blocks
we asked the subject to do one of these
particular tests
every block is made up of 40 40 uh 40
trials and on each trial the subject
must remember the task that they are
currently performing they're instructed
at the nature they're instructed at the
very beginning of the block what the
task they're going to be performing in
that particular block in addition to the
task instructions they receive
instructions
about response type so they can respond
either by making us a code to the left
or to the right or by
pushing a button yes or no
the neural data that we collect as
subjects are performed in this task is a
single spiking single unit spiking data
this data is collected from patients
that have interactable epilepsy
in the top right you'll see an
anatomical scan
from an example patient the highlighted
electric the highlighted areas in green
and in red
demonstrate the location of
example electrodes that are targeting
the amygdala and hippocampus in this
particular patient
in addition to the local fill potentials
that we record from these electrodes we
can also extract spiking activity and
this is the basic currency for most
we're looking at today
in a single session we can record from a
variety of different variety variety of
different areas the areas that we're
going to focus
focus on here
include the medial frontal cortex and
specifically the pre-sma and the dorsal
anterior cingulate cortex as well as the
hippocampus and then make it land the
medial temporal lobe
in a typical session we can report from
up to 120 cells or 130 cells i can
on the right i have shown i'm showing an
example raster plot that evolves of the
activity over a period of 10 seconds
from all of these cells in a single
session and what you might be able to
appreciate that in response to these
different images as we're showing them
to the subject there is these there are
these valleys of synchronized activity
throughout the brain
on the right i've highlighted the areas
from which these cells are recorded
and in in addition note that some of
these areas are have a gray background
and some don't
this indicates that they are recorded
from the left or the right hemisphere
so
in this particular task we're recording
from these two large structures in the
brain needle frontal cortex and the
medial temporal lobe we are very
interested in the communication and the
degree to which activity in these two
areas is uh
synchronized during the memory task and
during the categorization task
now apart in addition to their
scientific interest in this in this
pathway miscommunication between the
different cortex and the medial temporal
lobe there's a lot of clinical interest
in this particular pathway
since it's being implicated in a variety
of mental resources including
schizophrenia and alzheimer's disease
our hypothesis in this particular study
is that this pathway and the
communication between these two areas is
upregulated when the subject is
performing a memory task
so
without further ado we'll look at some
of the population responses as the
subjects are doing this task and we'll
start with
the single unit activity that we see
that we observe in the medial temporal
lobe specifically in the hippocampus and
in the amygdala
the population response as the subject
is doing this test in the media temporal
lobe is actually quite varied
a lot of the cells that we record from
have uh
are visually selective what that means
is that given the object categories
that we use in this particular that the
images are sampled from and that we use
in this particular task they are
strongly selective for a specific visual
specific object category in this
particular case and this cell that you
see here on the right is strongly tuned
to images of monkeys
in addition to these visually selective
cells we also have we also find a lot of
memory selective cells so these cells do
not encode anything about the visual but
the object the category of the object
that is on the screen but rather whether
the object that the subject is currently
viewing is familiar or is novel note
that this is a signal that can only
arise throughout the duration
of the task this is not something that
exists a priority as subjects become
increasingly more familiar with a subset
of the images this the strength of
tuning in these particular cells
also increases
in addition to these two basic types of
tuning
we also see a lot of cells that have
mixed selectivity for example we might
see cells that
or the familiarity or the novelty of an
item but for only as
specifically for a uh
object categories for example faces
so
given that there's so much heterogeneity
across the population perhaps there's a
better way to summarize all of the
responses that we see
instead of showing you individual cells
what i'll do instead is accumulate the
responses across all of the cells as
shown here in this heat map and i'm
going to plot the average condition i'm
going to calculate the average uh
activity for each one of those cells for
one of the eight possible conditions and
these conditions correspond to
the cartesian product of three binary
variables
first binary variable is whether an item
is novel or familiar the second binary
variable is the task that the subject is
actually performing when they see an
image in this case whether they're
performing an object recognition task or
categorization test or if they're
performing a familiarity detection task
the third binary variable is what the
object
object category is
so in general we use for we sample from
four object categories but for the
purposes of this illustration and to
make the to drive the point across i'm
going to reduce it and only consider
images of faces and fruits
incidentally it just so happens that
their memory and their overall memory
performance on this task is best for
these two image categories
if we now look at the um condition
averages the average activity across the
entire population for these age
conditions and project this uh this
matrix into a three-dimensional space we
actually recover really nice
geometric representation
so each one of these condition averages
here marked as one you know one two
three and four
is is uh corresponds to one of the
conditions on on the left the planes
that i've highlighted corresponded to
task one and task two blue corresponding
to uh instances the four conditions when
the subject is in a categorization block
and red
corresponding to instances when the
subject is performing a memory task
what i've also plotted in this
three-dimensional space is um a plane
that divides items that are new
conditions that correspond to new
instances what instances when the images
are new from instances when images are
familiar
i can also plot a hyperplane that
separates instances when
the item is a face and instances when an
item is a fruit there's a couple of
things that i'd like to point out in
this kind of arrangement in this kind of
geometrical structure
let's focus on being able to decode
whether something is new and old in only
a subset of the conditions so i've
highlighted here condition 1 and
condition 3.
these correspond to a new face and an
old face or a familiar face
note that a decoder that fits to
actually read out the familiarity
information from these two conditions
generalizes very nicely to instances
that have never been seen before so it
can also report the familiarity of
whether an image of a fruit is familiar
or if it is not
this kind of generalization does not
work
does not only work across images but
also works across tasks note that
training a decoder on in one task uh for
example in this case uh training and
decoder
larity information uh during the
categorization task generalizes very
well to into the memory task
the same thing is true for
visual information we can train a
decoder in one task here this
corresponds to
conditions one and two so we can train a
decoder to read out instrument whether
something is a face or a fruit in the
categorization task and we can test
whether this generalizes to the uh
memory task and we can see that this
kind of geometrical structure and this
kind of representational scheme allows
for
very nice generalization across
across variables and most importantly
across task
this
however is not true everywhere in the
brain so what i've shown you so far is
data from the medial temporal lobe and
i've reproduced that data in the graph
that's in the top left here we can we
can see the same nice geometrical
structure we were just looking at if we
were not to do the same exact analysis
but for data recorded in the media
frontal cortex we see that these
while this information is highly
decodable it is much more distorted
we know this is decodable because we can
actually perform this analysis and
that's what the top the bottom two
graphs actually show they show uh
decoding in the medial temporal lobe and
the media fluency cortex
with respect to image category in the
left plot and with respect to
familiarity in the right plots notice
that i've we've all also plotted the
decoding performance separately for each
category a subset is separate for each
task
um what we can already appreciate is
that while the decoding values that we
get within the medial temporal lob for
both image category and familiar
familiarity are largely mostly stable
across tasks in the medial frontal
cortex there is a great degree of
variability as a function of task
the critical analysis here though is the
test for generalization and the way we
do this is by fitting a decoder for
either familiarity or for the actual
visual category of the item on the
screen in one task and testing how
successful is this um this classifier
and reading out information that same
information from the other task so in
this particular case we're going to fit
a decoder one task and test in the other
and that's exactly what we do and what
we find is that while in the media
temporal lobe the coding
the coding for both image category and
familiarity is largely stable and by
stable we mean that the same decoder fit
in one task works very well with the
other task in the medial frontal cortex
it is
the the ability to decode this
information is
significantly reduced a better way to
summarize all of this data all of this
information is with a metric that we
call the generalization index this is
essentially a metric that measures how
decodable the information is within task
and normalize this with the ability to
decode same information across tasks
what you will appreciate from this plot
is that while in for both memory and in
this case by mem i'm referring to
familiarity for both familiarity and for
image category in the media temporal
lobe we can decode this information very
well and the generalization index is
close to one in the medial frontal
cortex the generalization index is
significantly below one
so these kinds of geometrical structures
these kind of representational uh format
that allows for for
generalization across
tasks and across many different kinds of
variables arises in a lot of other
different situations probably just for
for um
for i what i find particularly
interesting is that this kind of coding
scheme also arises for example in word
embedded
um in this now
uh
uh seminal paper from 2013 uh that looks
at semantic embeddings and different
words we can find that concepts such as
whether something is male or female are
abstract with respect to um
with respect to the actual things that
we are looking at for example the coding
vector between king and queen is
parallel to the coding encoding vector
between man and woman suggesting that
this concept of whether something is
male and female generalizes well and is
not specific to a particular uh instance
if the same is true for example for verb
tense and country capital
so these kinds of formats are very
similar this kind of representation
scheme is very similar to what we find
in the medial temporal lobe for
familiarity and per image category where
the coding vectors between things that
are familiar and things that are novel
are generalized well across tasks and
across
any of the task variables
so so far we focused on representation
of familiarity and representation of
image category in the task but what
about choice
for that we're going to zoom in on the
uh popular
the population activity in the medial
frontal cortex
the middle frontal cortex shows in this
particular task has a great degree of uh
tuning for choice i'm showing you here
the raster plot for an example cell
across all 320 trials aligned with the
onset of the image
now if we were to split these uh this
raster plot into instances when the
subject was performing memory task or
categorization task we'll see that
there's a very strong preference for uh
for memory trials and if we were to
split this raster plot even further into
trials where the subject said yes or no
and note that in this case yes and no
correspond to something different in
categorization trials yes could be an
answer to a question of the type is this
an image of a fruit and yes in the
memory trials is the answer to the
question have you seen this image before
if we were to split now by further more
by choice we'll know
we'll we'll observe that not only is
there choice choice coding not sorry not
only
their task coding but there's also
choice code and that choice coding is
specific to one particular task in this
case uh to the memory task
there's a lot of heterogeneity in the
population and much like we see choice
coding specific cells that code choice
specifically for the memory task we also
see a cell set code for choice in the
categorization task as is shown here
so what we'd like to know is how the
representations of choice are affected
not just by the task but also by this
instruction uh for response type so note
that there are four contextual signals
uh there are two contextual signals the
subject must always remember when they
begin a trial the first is what task
they're currently in are they answering
a memory question or a categorization
question and the second is the
instruction regarding the response type
are they communicating their choice with
a button press or are they
communicating their choice with
a sakad to the left and to the right
i'm going to perform now i'm going to
summarize the data across the media from
the cortex in a similar way uh
as the familiarity and in image category
information in the media template what
that means is that i'm going to take all
of the average activity across all of
the cells meter from the cortex and
we're going to project it into a
three-dimensional space so that we can
get
some intuition for exactly what changes
uh or
get an idea of how this representation
of choice changes as a function of
response type and for
task type
so
these eight conditions correspond to the
cartesian product of three binary
variables in this case the binary
variables are different than before the
binary variables in this case correspond
first this corresponds to choice so yes
or no the second binary variable
corresponds to
task type categorization or memory and
the third binary variable corresponds to
whether
the instructions
were for the instructions
if
the subject was instructed
to use a button press or to use this
account
the eight points that are plotted to the
eight condition averages that are
plotted here they're projected in this
three-dimensional space
are exactly the same in the top graph
and in the bottom graph what's different
is that in the top graph i've
highlighted the planes the planes that
connect all conditions
when the subject was uh performing a
button press
and in the bottom plot
i've highlighted all of the conditions
or i've
labeled all of the conditions that where
the subject was performing
a categorization task or a memory task
you can already begin to appreciate
there's a lot of a great degree of
correspondence um in um
where these can be in the location of
these
of these condition averages as a
function of of a change in response type
and as a
and a lack of correspondence when there
is a change in categorization but we can
probably sorry when there is a change in
task
we can summarize this even better with
a cross cross conditioner cross task
decoding performance
so if we train in this what these graphs
show is training uh decoder to read out
choice information in one particular
instance in this case in the top you can
see we're training on one particular
type of response for example training a
choice decoder only on button press
trials and testing its performance on
scott travis
in the bottom we do something similar
but instead of training the conditions
of relevance the conditions of relevance
here are the test types we train on
either categorization and test on memory
or test trainer memory intestinal
categorization and what's very clear is
that while there is very strong
generalization for for uh the way that
choice is is represented uh across
response types there is a very a
significant lack of generalization in uh
in the case when
uh the task changes
so so far we've looked at populations of
cells within an area and we've looked at
representations of familiarity we've
looked at representations of
visual category of the item
and representations of choice as a
function of response type and as a
function of task type
one thing that we're particularly
interested in is looking at the
communication between medial temporal
lobe and medial frontal cortex as
subjects perform or alternate between
these two different task types the
memory task and the categorization task
and uh recall that our hypothesis was
that
this pathway this synchrony the
synchrony uh level of synchronization
between these areas is going to be
significantly up regulated during the
memory task now there's uh many many
ways of measuring synchrony in
simultaneously recorded uh
in
experimental settings where data from
two different areas is recorded
simultaneously for example you can look
at synchrony between field field
recordings or you can look at specs by
correlations
and we performed all of this analysis
but in the interest of time i'm going to
in this particular presentation i'm
going to focus on the results that we
got from
an approach that mixes across modalities
so in this particular case we're going
to look at
a metric called spike field coherence
specifically we're looking at
the degree to which spiking activity in
the medial frontal cortex is coordinated
by oscillations in this distal area in
the medial temporal lobe
so
every for every single cell there is
a number of different combinations that
we have with this distant
distant area
recall that every single electrode
that's inside in an area has a bundle of
virus so we can actually compute spike
field coherence or
synchrony between the activity of the
cell the spike activity of the cell and
the oscillations in this distal area
with with many different electrodes in
this particular case we have seven
possible combinations of cell and and
electro possibilities
i'm showing here uh i'm showing you here
an example cell in the in the middle
frontal cortex and specifically in the
dorsal anterior synthetic
cortex
and the degree to which the activity of
the cell synchronizes with oscillations
in the hippocampus across the seven
electrons
at the very bottom of this plot you'll
see that i've split now
this metric of pairwise phase
consistency as a function of the task
that the subject was performing what you
can already appreciate is that this
synchrony at roughly seven seven hertz
or so which is in the theta range is
much stronger during the memory task
than it is during the categorization
task
and across all possible cell electric
pairs
and
in 33 sessions we had uh 8 822 cell
electro cell electric pairs with which
we can actually do this analysis we see
that there is very very strong
modulation of synchrony specifically in
the theta band with the peak at 5.5
hertz
what is not shown here but is actually
available in in
the published version in in this in
manuscript is that not only does this
asus affect data specific but it's also
cell type specific
meaning cells that are much more
strongly tuned to uh that represent
choice specifically during the memory
task have a much stronger much stronger
coherence with
oscillations in the medium hyperlope
than those cells that
include choice specifically during the
categorization test
so
this hypothesis we have if you recall we
hypothesized that the inter-area
coherence between mfc and mtl is much
stronger during memory retrieval
what i haven't shown you here is that
the degree of the synchrony is also
predictive of correct memory retrieval
and if you're interested in seeing those
results i'd like to refer you to the uh
the published manuscript
so i'd like to leave you with a video
summary of all of the things of
of some of the key results that we've
seen so far and i'll describe to you
exactly
here
so we designed this task that asks the
subjects to alternate between
either a categorization question or a
memory question in both instances the
subject reports either has produces a
binary choice saying either yes or no
what we observe
is that the choice activity or the
choice representations occupy different
subspaces during the categorization
task and during the memory task
in addition we also find that during the
memory task
in addition we also find that during the
memory task that the activity in the uh
of the spiking activity in the medial
frontal cortex is very strongly
regulated by theta oscillations in the
medial temporal lobe
so on that note i'd like to thank you
for your attention intention and i'd
also like to thank all of the people
that
it's correct specifically i'd like to
thank the rudis elder lab and my advisor
uli ruthesauser the edo slash at the
california institute of technology and
stephen fousey at the center for
theoretical neuroscience at columbia
university
you